you know the dreamers those dream
they're all
those cute little kids brought over to
america
through no fault of their own illegally
but their dream they have dreams you
know and that's why we need to
completely ignore all of our laws and
completely open our border just so that
we could have more dreams here
we don't have enough dreams in america
so one of the dreamers
a 26-year-old coyoamy miguel ruiz has
just been sentenced to 28 years in
prison
after being found guilty of using social
media to entice minors into performing
sexual acts and producing pornography in
exchange for money
in a statement given to the daily wire
immigration and customs enforcement
confirmed that miguel ruiz first came to
the united states as an illegal alien in
the late 1990s and was granted deferred
action for childhood arrivals that's
daca that's the obama program
sometime thereafter
you know it's just there that's our
strength
our the the dreamers and the immigration
and all that diversity that's that's our
strength
right we wouldn't have nearly as much uh
child pornography if no that's not fair
michael
that's not fair you're gonna what you're
gonna say not you but what the liberals
would say is michael come on that's
cheap a citizen could have done that too
some
american citizens do that it's not just
illegal aliens who
entice
kids into performing sexual acts and
produce pornography in exchange for
money and all that
true you're right
however
this particular crime would not have
been committed in the united states
if we didn't tolerate illegal
immigration
this didn't need to happen
we don't need the illegal immigrants
here they don't help america
they don't help at all
it's nice for them that they get to stay
in america
we all probably have some friends who
were illegal aliens or who came here as
kids or who maybe they were illegal but
then they got put on some kind of path
toward we and and that's nice it's nice
for them
in the individual cases of some friend
that we like
i guess that's good
but generally speaking
illegal aliens do not help america they
only hurt america
they only make the country worse
all of these crimes
whether it's a cyber crime like this
whether it's a car accident
whether it's a murder whether it's a
rape whether it's
whatever crime
committed by an illegal alien in america
did not need to happen
because we could have just enforced our
border
and it doesn't matter if illegal aliens
are statistically
more likely or less likely or exactly
the same likelihood of committing some
crime
they shouldn't be here to begin with
okay and so
a serious country
a serious country that put our nation's
interests first whether we're talking
about
the american cultural identity whether
we're talking about american workers
whether we're talking about our way of
life and our traditions
would not tolerate this kind of stuff
okay but we are not a serious country
really anymore
and so we don't have the integrity of
our beliefs we don't have the integrity
of our national symbols we don't have
the integrity of our borders and without
a border there's no such thing as a
country
this should worry
any
anyone who likes
i'm not even going to say the most
ardent patriot anyone who just kind of
likes being in this country when things
are going relatively well
we can't go on like this forever folks
you can't go on forever having well over
two million illegal aliens jumping the
border every year and and radicals in
the country tearing down our statues and
ripping down all of our traditions and
all of our social more is you can't that
can't go on forever it can't even go on
for very long
i'm so glad you like that clip i like
that clip too that was pretty good i
need you to ring the bell subscribe that
way you will get the notifications when
new videos come out really you ought to
head over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts type in the michael
knowles show t-h-e space m-i-c-h-a-e-l
space canon wlas space
s-h-o-w-period
subscribe leave a five-star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you